partout ton Ukraine des infrastructures
électriques sous le feu des missiles
russes en une semaine 30% des centrales
électriques du pays ont été détruites
selon le président zellenski alors les
autorités ukrainiennes ont pris mardi de
nouvelles restrictions pour limiter de
20 % la consommation d'électricité une
première depuis le début de la guerre
l'opérateur du réseau national a mis en
garde contre des coupures de courant
dans tout le pays pouvant durer jusqu'à
4 heures entre 7h et 23h depuis le 10
octobre le système énergétique ukrainien
subit plus d'attaque ennemis que durant
les 8 mois de guerre le climat se
dégrade assurez-vous d'avoir chargé au
téléphone batterie externe et d'avoir de
l'eau des lampes de poche et des piles
avant 7h demain matin il est possible
qu'avec l'arrivée du froid nous
sollicitions votre aide encore plus
fréquemment de nombreuses villes ont
annoncé remplacé les transports publics
électriques et réduit la fréquence des
services par anticipation l'État peut
également compter sur les efforts des
Ukrainiens pour diminuer leur
consommation
nous sommes prêts pour les coupures de
courant on a des bougies on a chargé nos
batteries l'Ukraine est prête à gagner
on a été tous les appareils électriques
à la maison et recommandations du
gouvernement doivent être prises au
sérieux jusqu'à présent nous n'avons pas
utilisé le chauffage on a acheté de
nouvelles couettes des oreillers on se
prépare je ne sais pas comment nous
allons rester au chaud
ces derniers jours Moscou a intensifié
son offensive endommageant des
infrastructures énergétiques cruciales
dans tout le pays une arme pour
fragiliser davantage l'Ukraine à
l'approche de l'hiver et tenter de
reprendre l'ascendant